this is a Fox News Alert just moments
ago the White House announcing that its
delegation that was set to be led by
Treasury Secretary Stephen minuchin will
no longer attend the world economic
summit in Davos Switzerland staying out
of a consideration for the 800,000 great
American workers not receiving pay and
to ensure his team can assist as needed
President Trump has cancelled his
delegations trip to the World Economic
Forum in Davos Switzerland that from
Sara Sanders just a few moments ago this
of course after the president canceled
the military aircraft for the Speaker of
the House and Democratic Congress and
lawmakers to head overseas to a number
of different stops